telling the other guy listen do this you
know at least get the ball started for
him right i want you to see the
technique i want you to go home and go
why my arm so strong because i'm pushing
instead of escaping and putting my knee
up right and you remember to put your
knee up and little things like that you
just get a lot more personal attention
at least i do yeah man it's a good
little class
i'm ready let's do it [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's october 26th
halloween week trick-or-treat
[ __ ]
this show is brought to you by club w
what is club w club w
is the best way to get wine it's a brand
new club
and when you go to club w you fill out a
questionnaire on their site and they
send you three bottles or as many
bottles as you want a great one that's
unique to them they are the only people
you're gonna get their wine from
go to club w dot com slash joey right
now to get fifty percent off of your
first order that's right club w club w
is offering our listeners fifty percent
off of your first order when you go to
club w dot com slash joey so stop
wasting time and money and messing
around at retail stores and start
drinking wine that you know you're going
to love just go to w dot com slash joey
show is brought to you by onit.com go to
audit.com and use codewordchurch to get
10 off all the great optimization
products
go to naileditlife.com and use codeword
joeyds to get 20 off the premier vapor
pen on the market and they are also the
makers of los gumi shimanos if you live
in california and go to hitesigs.com
better tasting longer lasting the proof
is in the vape they have e-cigarettes
and e-cigars for you
oh [ __ ] kick that lead
kick that horse
oh [ __ ]
what
monday october 26th
we're going old school tonight
[ __ ]
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what
a couple of [ __ ] gorilla biscuits
a couple bumps and two
a couple of [ __ ] long island iced
teas
you're jumping up and down to this
[ __ ] here what
oh [ __ ] keep keeping this [ __ ]
only right here huh
when i was a senior in [ __ ] high
school this was the jam
that's how old this jam is kick it up
lee hit
the church or what's happening now you
bad [ __ ]
call me
what's the story did you go to like
school dances to this or i can't even
imagine going to school dance but
no uh
when i was a senior
january was when
you know we would always go out in
jersey to different places
but when i was a senior that january
was when we first started drifting over
into the city
after the bars were closed
so 3 a.m new jersey bars are closed
and we would drift into the city
and in those days it was like
yeah studio 54 was the mecca
trust me i was not going to studio 54. i
wouldn't even know they wouldn't even
let a guy like me stand online in studio
54. oh wow so we would go to the lower
end ones the
the whatever club where it was like 12
bucks all you could drink
we went to the church a couple times
which never impressed me that limelight
so did you because you've talked about
before how they used to have paper
licenses did you even use those or was
it just they let you in or like because
yeah no they would proof you they would
okay listen man
as in those days as long as they were
covered that's all they gave a [ __ ]
about
now they scrutinize you they'll take the
id from you and call
and called the cops
you're getting 12.50 an hour who gives
the [ __ ] give the kids what you didn't
try to sneak into a club but these dudes
take their jobs too [ __ ] seriously
yeah and write it for you know for 10
bucks an hour you're going to scrutinize
some kid just give the kid the id and go
listen kid don't come back down here and
don't [ __ ] me but now they pull
people out of lines and call 9-1-1
is it really worth the aggravation 30
years ago as long as they were covered
hey man he showed me an id
let me see the idea you showed him this
ain't you okay what am i ordaining i
don't [ __ ] don't get ten dollars an
hour what do i give a [ __ ] right i mean
follow me yes it's the same [ __ ]
principle and did you know cause we're
like in when i was going to high school
it got around right that a certain
chinese place wouldn't go right yeah
certain this is the same thing
end of the school year
more and more once a month twice a month
but we would you know johnny bananas and
we go to like uh i forget to like the
rooftop and
you know and do like a grammar blow and
meet other [ __ ] morons and
do a grammar blow with them and then
and then that's it i i once i saw that
i couldn't go back to just going to bars
anymore you know like once i saw that
type of and i wasn't a big new york city
nightlife guy i was going to say you
don't sound like a club no no no no no
no no no
the only way you could drag me to those
things
is if we're doing coke okay i was half
in the [ __ ] bag
and you had quaaludes and i was i cut
into an eight ball with you guys and
four of us were going into the city if
three people are gonna leave with the
eight ball you chipped in on you might
as well go
the only reason i would go and i can't
lie to you i had a good time i'm not
gonna sit here and told you tell you i
had a miserable time was it my type of
lifestyle no
no i couldn't go out every night it's
funny because on the way here i drove my
wife's car tonight and i was listening
to studio 54 on sirius okay and it was a
couple that they were interviewing and
they were talking about
raising two children he was a dentist
and she was uh something
and they raised two children and they
went to 3054
four nights a week
and they would tuck the kid in
the mother would come over and stay on
the couch and they would be home in time
to make breakfast with the kids at six
in the morning then he would take a nap
and go to his dental office he would
make all the appointments
for lunchtime
and he was talking about like
hanging out with truman capote and
uh liza minnelli and you know
just that was [ __ ] crazy
and i did go to stream 54 one time
but in 1983. and it was already done
that was done i went there with like a
friend of mine that knew somebody and
well what do you think as like a
relatively new parent when you hear
someone's going to studio 54 every night
that's what as a meeting judge somebody
like i don't look when you're hearing
that like are you saying that's awesome
they shouldn't do that like it just
seems like it's kind of
like it's crazy man if you're dropping
your kid off at some far in this [ __ ]
house
to to take care your child while you go
out jump up and down and snook blow
i think that's [ __ ] up
but i can't judge you but on the other
hand
if my mom comes over and stays with the
kids
and i got everything covered
yeah
i saw my mom live a [ __ ] hard life
that's why she died at 48 but i saw my
mom
live uh a bar life and try to take care
of a kid and balance it terry and i were
talking about it tonight i was watching
the chinese connection last night oh
yeah mercy was in the tub and i did the
periscope
and i saw i saw when i was in florida
somebody had tweeted me that bruce lee
was on all [ __ ] weekend on elray
so i didn't have el rey down there in
[ __ ] uh florida at the hotel
so last night i remembered and i put the
chinese connection on which they call
fist the fury
it got released as a
fist of fury but we changed it to the
chinese connection it's all the same
it's all the same okay so that's my
all-time favorite that's when his
teacher dies
and he avenges his teacher that's the
one i put on rogan that's
my all-time favorite bruce lee movies
he's he's just he's he's uh
he's basically
cursey ball crazy all right he's paul
cursey in that movie
he's gonna find out who killed this
teacher
he does not believe that the teacher
died of a pneumonia
and he plays that role you know
what i tried to explain that day on the
joe rogan podcast was how
intense he came on the scene bruce lee
like you see what ronda rousey's doing
now right with the internet and
everything
he was bigger without the internet
with nothing
so so when i came
one day i i'm at my friend's house right
these cousins i played with alcoholo and
he was older than me
and their aunts and their mom and my mom
and every sunday night the show used to
come on the green on it
and at the end some chinese guy would
bit-slap the [ __ ] out everybody and
every kid in the house would lose their
[ __ ] mind okay and start throwing
kicks and back and the parents have to
come and control yourselves
you know and then the combat was on the
rap patrol one of those shows which a
lot of you youngsters would never even
understand a lot of young people
this is old show rap patrol it's about
this [ __ ] open up with this jeep in
the desert and so at this point how many
stations were there do you think three
three okay there was abc nbc and cbs
there was some spanish stations but you
had to have a hangar
behind your tv with aluminum foil and
[ __ ] you know there was no cable no
nothing so do you think he would have
been as popular now who bruce lee oh my
god if he was popular with three
channels so three channels okay so all
of a sudden one day i don't know what
the [ __ ] the show is i know the show's
called the green horn it's a chinese
[ __ ] dude but at the end he just
karate chops everybody
okay and one day he disappears and i get
involved in a thing called life
okay he gets taken off the air in 68 or
69 which puts me at five or six
you know i'm involved in this thing
called life when you're four
and you want a kick and they're telling
you you can't kick but you see a [ __ ]
chinese dude on tv kicking people on
sunday [ __ ] nights
you lose your [ __ ] mind okay right
so then this [ __ ] chinese guy
disappears
all right and i went out with my life i
got into baseball
disco
sticky charlie i got into all that [ __ ]
148th street
and then one day he reappears
in this [ __ ] movie of him flying
through the end i'm looking at this guy
and i'm going i know this [ __ ] guy
and then talking to the kids on the
street they're like yeah that's the
[ __ ] arena on it
oh
so the first movie was originally called
the big boss
which they switched to fist of fury
which is him he goes back to work
in a nice factory his mother sends him
to [ __ ] some planet and he gets there
and he hooks up with the [ __ ] cousin
and the cousin gets him a job at an ice
factory
and then the [ __ ] cut it's 18 [ __ ]
chinese people in the apartment
and one cut two cousins don't come back
and all these movies are in chinese
chinese with subtitles subtitles but at
the time
they had already put english
dubbing
so that's fist of fury and then he
[ __ ] fights the boss and
so at the end he beats the boss that's
why it's called the big boss okay all
right so then
i caught the tail end of that i'm not
gonna lie to anybody and tell you i saw
that in the in the movie theater
i don't even know how you
movie
i think didn't it come on i've heard it
just came on tv at a certain point like
you had a way to something
excuse me and then something
miraculously happened
i was watching happy days
okay right it was the first season of
[ __ ] happy days i think i could
double check with you guys i'll look it
up look it up it was the first season of
happy days happy days i think used to
come on abc on tuesday nights
all right this is what i'm thinking here
i'm thinking okay go ahead look at it
but what am i looking up happy days in
bruce lee look up bruce lee chinese
connection release date
okay
it's going to say 71-72
right
it was released november 7th of 72. okay
so now
look up happy days tv series
74 to 84 so two years after so it was uh
unless you caught it at like uh no no we
were watching something else we were
watching a different type of show that
tuesday it was like a tuesday night on
tv
and what you did at catholic school at
sacred heart school for boys was you got
out of school
after two and then you went to study
hall from two to 3 30
and then at 3 30 you went to the
dormitory you changed
and you played from four to six
at six you went in for dinner at 6 30
you went back to your room and did
homework for a half hour what what time
do you think it was what's tuesday i
don't remember i don't [ __ ] know
because on
starting at eight it's temperature
rising
and then abc movie of the week starting
8 30. that's [ __ ] crazy and then uh
mod y50 how abc that's that's cbs yeah
cbs and then nbc was bonanza the bold
ones and nbc reports wow yeah two tv
shows a [ __ ] tuesday night movie of
the [ __ ] week and there used to be a
sunday night [ __ ] movie of the week
and then and then there was uh the abc
movie went from 8 30 into when it ended
and then 11 o'clock cbs started at 9 30.
so there was two movies so you maybe you
start on one of those well no no what
i'm saying is it was a commercial or
something that was on okay and we were
we were kids we had to watch tv at night
right and all of a sudden that trailer
for chinese connection came on
and i'm here i am in a dormitory with
the bottom line
30 [ __ ] kids between the ages of
eight and nine like we were in a
dormitory with the third and fourth
grades and they're all boys right all of
us are boys we third graders on one side
fourth graders on the other side you
were talking about it this morning with
john bud who's doing some younger kid
karate classes now you're like when
they're that age all you want to do is
like is fight we i did that from the
from the age i can remember i did
taekwondo karate wrestling i did all
that so now
it's mediocre martial arts at that time
at this country
was
and all of a sudden we're all watching
tv
and lee out of nowhere this chinese guy
starts beating people up
and he takes new chucks out and then
everybody's jaw dropped and i remember
when the said coming friday
like everybody was like we're going
we're going and everybody started
yelling and the nuns like you got to
stop you got to stop you got to stop
nobody's going to go nowhere if you
don't stop talking
like every kid's head blew up and after
that it was all over once the chinese
connection hit in 72 it was like ronda
rousey
it was like [ __ ] ronda rousey
everybody was dressing up with bruce lee
[ __ ] everybody had those chinese shoes
on who wasn't going to [ __ ] china who
didn't meet bruce lee in california who
did you know it was bruce lee
it was [ __ ] bruce lee immediately
immediately like months he was he was
into [ __ ] national because those were
considered like spaghetti westerns for
clint eastwood he had to go back to hong
kong
to make those and eat [ __ ] and make
those again but those made him a star
last night i watched the ending of the
chinese connection which i i had tears
in my eyes at the end i forgot how good
it was and
my hat's off to robert rodriguez my
hat's off
hat's [ __ ] off to that dude
because i read somewhere see i knew
about the weekend
but i knew about it through twitter
about two weeks ago and i read somewhere
that he was doing it all weekend and
he had obtained the rights to show the
whole movie without the cuts
so it was the way the director intended
it for you to see it like i watched
return of the dragon there was nudity i
never saw a nudity ah you follow me that
was nudity in the chinese connection
there's nudity when they're after
whatever ugly [ __ ] chinese women with
little titties are like japanese women
they got ugly [ __ ] and she's always
so disappointing as a kid yeah like well
yeah you want to see big tits like
chicks got nice tits but she had a
[ __ ] up face and you know when you're
10 you don't want to see that you want
to see a [ __ ] model you know you
don't want to see hong kong [ __ ]
fooly
so it was just uh
it was uh
what really [ __ ] me up about last
night
that [ __ ] me up a couple weeks ago
because i'm trying to write this book
so i'm trying to write an intro and i
was thinking of something what really
[ __ ] me up
and you know what really [ __ ] me up
lee i got left back i never realized
until i wrote this [ __ ] thing how
much it [ __ ] me up because
it really made me insecure and it really
made me had to prove myself but it
really made me have to prove myself to
me
which is the weirdest thing i could say
i had been at a catholic school
two years
the deal and i was telling terry this
and terry's like you got to be [ __ ]
me
when i went when i got out of the
catholic school in the fifth grade and
went to north bergen to mckinley in the
sixth right
my mom didn't wake up in the mornings
anymore
there was cereal there was eggs there
was bacon there was toast and butter
there were sodas there was juice there
was milk
and there was money
you do what the [ __ ] you want at that by
that time my mom didn't wake up for
breakfast no more was she mad that you
loved catholic school you were just
older no no no no no my mom felt
i was old enough to make breakfast to
make breakfast two eggs two pieces of
bacon wash your dishes
you know if you're really [ __ ] hungry
if you're really [ __ ] hungry you'll
make breakfast and guess what lee it
taught me how to make two eggs yeah and
then a friend of mine taught me how to
make a cheese omelette with american
cheese and that was it after that i
never [ __ ] made an egg again i made
cheese on it's two eggs with a little
milk
pepper and salt and i [ __ ] make an
omelet
but that wasn't the only like she was
like if you want to wear those pants i
do laundry twice a week but if you want
to wear those pants you got to do those
for your own laundry
you're following me if you want to wear
them more than one day yeah like my
mom's like if you want those
if you wore those wednesday and you want
to wear those friday it's not going to
happen because i'm not doing laundry
till sunday
so my mom did laundry like sundays and
tuesdays or saturdays and tuesdays
saturdays and tuesdays
so she was like it's not going to happen
you want the [ __ ] pants that bad you
wash them so guess what lee i learned
how to wash my own pants did you have
that in the house or do you have to go
to a no i had a washer dryer right in
the house and we had the line outside
the whole [ __ ] thing what spanish
people thought we put a line outside so
by that time that was the treatment i
had like you're old enough to take care
of this [ __ ] i'm not gonna wake you up
for school
i'm not gonna wake you up for school
and there was a couple times i was late
and she was [ __ ] furious right
[ __ ] furious you know she didn't
believe in that [ __ ] at all but then
something happened me i got left back
so the rope she had given me
that fire backfired but i couldn't tell
her i couldn't eat [ __ ] [ __ ] there
was no way
there was no way i was gonna eat [ __ ]
from my mom there was no way it was the
roughest [ __ ] to eat
she knew how to shovel it dog
she gave me that rope and i [ __ ] up
that means i wouldn't ever get that
freedom again
so i hid it from her
so guess what i had to do i had to step
my game up
i had to step my game up to cover
everything
so i had to [ __ ] get a's plus
so there would be no misunderstanding so
ever since that time i became a re i was
always a good student without even
thinking about it just sitting in class
and listening yeah if you can't get a b
sitting in class listening taking little
notes for 45 minutes you deserve to
[ __ ] be a [ __ ] mother
or something that's pretty crazy though
do you think
like what do you think your life would
have been if you had told your mom you
got left back like that seems like
a quick like a turning point like well
here's the other thing i was thinking
about this also
last night you know i'm watching this
[ __ ] bruce lee movie
first off
i went to fort lauderdale this week and
i saw some kids i grew up with
and one of the kids i always see that i
didn't see this time his name is sir
billy o'pino
me and sabilio go back to [ __ ] sacred
heart
that's
second that's third to fifth grade jesus
okay his dad on the uh
refrigeration
repair service okay
and he was friends with my mom and my
stepdad and he did all that he's cuban
dude
so sebelia was his son so me and sebelia
hung out
a kid named mikey and the kid supito
after bruce lee came out
us four were inseparable
because supito
and mikey
their parents were both superintendents
of a building right which means they had
access to a build a basement
so we would go to their basements and
dress up with karate guys
and beat the [ __ ] out of each other and
do forms and hang bags and [ __ ] iron
palm techniques you always have the
hookup all through life you have a
friend who does this the two of the kids
can you believe that even happening with
the [ __ ] kids their parents ran
buildings
so we had access to basements you had a
fight club and we had like a little
fight club but we didn't beat each other
up like that i can't no we didn't that
was excellent you know people got kicked
through a wall or something time to time
you get aggressive
you know and you know it happens you
don't me these are your [ __ ] goombas
you're not there to hurt them did you
pick up the nunchucks at that point the
end we did everything we did everything
we everybody walked around with lumps on
their head because when you're first
learning the loot chucks you you miss
you you miss sometimes and you clock
yourself all the time all the time you
[ __ ] your elbow up you [ __ ] the back of
your head up you [ __ ] yeah right here
oh my god you clock yourself in the jaw
that's why i gave up on the back of the
elbow and the [ __ ] back of the
i don't know how many people walking
around half [ __ ] because they had
new checks today they [ __ ] bounced
him off the head
but he created such an impact
but i was thinking about sibilio pino
this is the saddest thing i told my wife
this was sitting there last night she
says what's the matter like i'm watching
this
and i got to be [ __ ] honest with you
it says 1972
right i read 1972 that clocked me at
nine
nine
and again
it's 1972 ladies and gentlemen
so i want you to close your eyes for a
second and think of how different life
was and how slow it was
and yes there was perverts and yes there
was [ __ ] gay people trying to get
their dick sucked and there was
everything
not to the magnitude there is today
but my mom would let me walk how far is
it from blockbuster
on lancashire do you know what you used
to be a blockbuster this jersey mike's
right right right how far do you think
of this from jersey mike's
to denny's on lancashire
at least a couple miles two months you
would think because it's it's like a few
main streets it's like four or five big
blocks my mom used to let me walk from
29th and bergen line avenue
to 48th and bergen line avenue
which is about a mile and a half you
have jesus
with four kids to catch the 10 30
chinese connection
so in those days i would come home
on thursday afternoons from catholic
school
my mom would go what are you doing so
you're going to stay home hell no i'm
going to the bar with you really
you're going to come spend time with
mommy hell no i'm going to come down and
hang out with you until nine and then
i'm going to go to el cinema and see
what movies playing down there
and i would walk to
the 10 o'clock film with supito
mike
and [ __ ] uh this pinot i did the same
thing but i was like 16 or 17 like you
did this at nine going to a ten o'clock
movie
walking home at
12 15
12 15 four [ __ ] nine year olds
walking home like jerk offs throwing
kicks in the air
punches telling stories about fights
that were never going to happen
you know four [ __ ] jerk-offs what is
that area like is it
that time it was industrial or is it
like woods no no no at that time 29th
and bergen line was the street you know
how broadway in new york city is the
street right and bergen line starts from
kelly's uh kennedy i'm so sorry i'm
sorry people from 90th street
in north bergen
and it goes all the way down to [ __ ]
hoboken i think all the way down to
first street so there's like restaurants
and businesses it starts with a park and
then but you pass a dunkin donuts and
you pass uh mcdonald's and then it's
it's uh
it's very white for a couple blocks once
you get to western new york it becomes
spanish you know once you get to 52nd
street that's where that poultry store
margalizano is where you go in the
chickens and [ __ ] then from there down
from 48th street down it's cuban
it's cuban all the way down to [ __ ]
in those days to like 16th street then
it was italian
you know pinot's pizzeria now i'm lying
to you like 20th street it became
italian you know are there
like other groups of your friends
walking home because like when groups
not home they'd be like groups
and these days there were people on the
streets but not to the magnitude that
you'd expect no but i'm saying did you
see like any other kids from your class
at those things [ __ ] no
[ __ ] no once in a while yeah like i went
to see the longest yard with john bender
in the afternoon i went to see you know
tommy in the afternoon there was a lot
of movies i went to in the afternoon
there was a lot of movies that went to
the eight o'clock
i remember going to see into the dragon
with my stepfather for the eight o'clock
but when i was at the bar on a friday or
saturday night i had two [ __ ] options
i could sit at the bar
and play pool
shuffleboard music play the congress
shake people down for money after all
that's done it's still [ __ ] 11
o'clock i got four hours to burn in that
[ __ ] four hours
listening to spanish music listening to
arguments
you know watching my mom [ __ ] dance
my stepdad come in he's pissed off
the ice machines broken there was always
some drama
so i would i would say [ __ ] it a movie
what are you [ __ ] kidding me
or training that's repeat those [ __ ]
yeah i brought my gear with me i'll come
down over there and we'll beat each
other up till midnight
and my mom would go how are you getting
back i'm walking no no i don't want you
walking call me and i'll send a cab over
there for you so sometimes i get a cab
home
uh okay but when i was with those kids
we [ __ ] walked what cab we walked
i mean
does it do you wish you had more
structure
i don't know
i don't know
i'm pretty much the example of the
opposite i am blown away by the rope
that i had it didn't really
hit me till last night that i was
watching that movie going
this came out in 71 to 72.
that clocks me at eight of [ __ ] nine
you mean i was walking from 29th street
to 48th street
on a [ __ ] every friday and saturday
watch movies dog i was a movie kid i
went to the [ __ ] movies as much as i
could
you know every movie that i could go
watch
and every martial art movie that came
out i went and watched two or three
[ __ ] times
really was this the thing you did almost
every friday with your friends that's
just that's crazy i loved i love going
to movies i love my friends who doesn't
that's how you learned
everything that's how you learn culture
what the [ __ ] was going on people were i
don't know
for me it was an escape
i was sitting there last night that at
that movie
think watching that [ __ ] movie last
night thinking how
as it got to the end
i remember like [ __ ] i'm gonna have to
go
after i walk home with my friends and do
this
i don't know what i'm walking into
like by 72 73 at the bar i never knew
what i was walking into so you'd go back
to the bar well well no no i'd walk over
the bridge and go to a discotheque yeah
i'd [ __ ] go to a bar back to my
mother's bar my house in those days was
in new york city oh that's why i had to
wait there till three so that's why new
jersey was nothing you were walking
around new york city yeah that's why you
know like i i had to be there till three
because we lived in new york when i was
10. oh
so you follow me once out my mom would
tell me once you're in jersey
there ain't no coming back there ain't
no 9 30 i'm tired
so there was a rule once i went to
jersey i was in till 3 a.m with them
i didn't leave the bar till 3 20 3 30
and by the time we got home 10 to 4
[ __ ] it then we go home my mom would
cook something we'd talk [ __ ] and i go
to [ __ ] bed in those days this is
when i was when i lived in new york city
that's crazy that is crazy
i mean i grew up my mom was struck my
dad kind of had he worked in nightclubs
so he was out til two or three in the
morning a lot
but he was home during the day and my
mom was super strict my dad was super
strict
and i just
the little kid in me is a little bit
jealous like i would have loved to do
that i also grew up in a town that
didn't have some of that stuff but i
would have loved to be able to walk to
the movies
but then
hearing all the crazy stuff you go
through maybe it wasn't like i don't
know i don't know if it was good or bad
okay what's the closest movie to my
house lancashire and [ __ ] magnolia
whatever that is over there right
what you're trying to ask me is if
mercy's 10
would i let her walk over there
from where i live
well
that's a million [ __ ] you know i'm
gonna say yes you you don't think so
that's super close i would love to tell
you that
i let her walk that i don't know
i just don't know because that i don't
trust dick anymore you can't
i don't trust dick anymore
it's uh it's scary but i remember you go
to a [ __ ] parade you get hit by a car
this weekend that fat little [ __ ]
chick
and the boyfriend's saying that he she
didn't do drugs i don't know what really
went down i can't watch those videos
anymore no i why you know you turn the
news on expecting a [ __ ] sunny day
and you see a story about somebody going
into some state fair in oklahoma or some
[ __ ] you didn't see it actually
i don't look at the news anymore man
because it's so interesting
that's why i walk my wife and the baby
to school on tuesdays wednesdays and
thursdays coming down i walk them and i
pick them up like if you're i hate all
those streets oh yeah hate them with all
my heart i hate all those streets over
there and she's only getting bigger
mercy
she's gonna get more money for her
you could get [ __ ] two thousand in
mexico five she's three or four
blonde there they got ten thousand for
[ __ ] you know these [ __ ] people are
animals that's how you have to think
yeah that's how you and i tell my wife i
tell everybody you know
i i don't know how you allow this in
this society i couldn't
but then what happens when she's i got
[ __ ] major league problems because if
you come to me
not you being you lee right but i'm
talking about joe parent comes to me
and says hey man i'm going to a [ __ ]
dodger game do you mind if your daughter
comes with my daughter to the game i'm
in a [ __ ] pickle
i'm in a [ __ ] pickle why
because
you know i just don't know lee
i just don't [ __ ] know but then what
happens when mercy turns 18
she goes to nyu or wherever she goes to
college
and if she's been
guarded her whole life maybe she'll walk
in harlem and get mugged and she won't
have like the street smarts part of it i
know
i know that's the other end that's the
other end
i think
i mean
i went i did stuff like that with other
parents but i think my mom probably
wouldn't have let me do with certain
parents so i think you'll probably like
right now you probably have certain
kids moms and dads
man let me tell you something i'm gonna
tell you right now
i don't have mercy in the car
as much as i should
because i smoke reefer
and i know this is going in if i'm
straight then i'll put mercy in the car
and i'll drive but if i'm not completely
straight
i'll let my wife drive and i do this
with my child so
i can never
what what if what if lee your child
comes over my house right and the
process isn't coming over
my other friend comes home we smoke a
ball while we're talking [ __ ] and i
gotta drive your kid back
you understand me i wouldn't do it i'll
uber that [ __ ] child over there with
my wife and uber back before i get in
the car with your child high that's how
i think
what i do on my own terms is what the
[ __ ] i do
what i do with mercy like she's she's
three if mercy is 18 i look in the face
and go hey i just date 600 [ __ ]
milligrams of debt
you want to take a ride to [ __ ]
valencia with me
you know you follow him saying yeah only
you because you're a lunatic would do
100 on the way back from san diego with
me when i'm with mercy in the car i
drive completely different really when
i'm with terry in the car i gotta drive
completely different you don't drive
like that with terry half and a half
but not with mercy in the [ __ ] oh
it's an experience with you but it's uh
i don't i there was one you're scared
for your child i don't know how your
parents do it but there was a one guy
one father at my high school who
everyone knew was drunk all the time so
i wouldn't get in the car with him
there was a like i've heard stories of
him like driving over meetings and stuff
like that so it happens but you have to
oh but um
yeah i mean i don't know how people send
their kids to school now i honestly
don't
and all that's really scary
and like like i used to make not make
fun of but my one like my mom was sad
that i was leaving for college i was
like yeah why like why are you so sad
like it's great and now i it's just it's
crazy to think
how much
like how much they rely on you and how
like you're in charge of a life it
freaks me out
you know first you went to college
which i was how far from your home 45
minutes i was close and you stayed at
home you lived in the dorm i lived in i
lived in the city so you you moved out
early
i moved down that [ __ ] you took loans
yeah and then i got a job in the movie
theater business
the only
the only summer i
spend at home the last time i lived with
my mom with half summer after freshman
year i went home to work
and after since then i haven't lived at
home
and for the past five years i've lived
3000 miles away
which is crazy and you left and came out
here yeah
were they upset
no where was dicky sciatica he was down
in florida already he was down in
florida when i was in college
but they they were never upset
i'm sure my mom misses me i know but i
mean i know she does but
she understands sometimes i do feel
guilty
that like why am i out here like she had
not surgery but she had a couple things
done the other day and i was like oh i
should be there to drive her but it's uh
she understands i think
your father's an interesting cat
yes he is i really learned a lot from
that two or three hours i spent with him
he's a funny dude you're a lucky dude to
still have him around yes i am thank god
it's uh funny i was sitting there with
him
and now i understand what you're saying
you know like there's some things that
you can't have your dad around when
you're doing
do you know what i'm saying like they
just don't feel right yeah like
it's uh it's weird i don't mind smoking
a joint if my kid's around or something
but there's just some stuff like
like even like hitting on somebody when
your dad's around would be weird
if he hit on somebody it just happened
to me actually and he's gonna hear this
now but he called me the day after i had
a porn director on my podcast and i
talked about how i used to know where
his porn was
and he called me
and was like he told me a story that he
was on a show once and told a story
about losing his virginity and his
parents called him and he was telling me
this and i wanted to crawl out of my own
skin that he had heard
that i used to watch his porn
and i just had to like change the
subject
it was it was the worst
and like it's just it's
i mean at this point like you're gonna
run into it with mercy at some point
she's there's thousands of hours of this
so it's kind of hard to be embarrassed
now
i don't watch porn well not porn but
she's not gonna find my [ __ ] stash
because i don't have a stash yeah but
then you also have one dirty magazine at
the house well you don't have to now but
one day she might log on your computer i
have nothing dirty on that you don't go
to u-porn i have the u-point yeah that's
all they need i don't know when the last
time i clicked onto you born
it pops up it goes away
back the [ __ ] computer it just shows
up and then usually you use it no i
don't i don't i don't
it's not that i used it it's not that i
put i ari told me [ __ ] 10 years ago
they were talking about porn when i used
to go on the road with those guys right
i knew nothing
do you not understand i knew nothing i
didn't know they would talk about
downloading and i i would just make
believe like
you know i don't know what's going on
you're doing a ton of downloading you're
like oh yeah i downloaded all the time
they wouldn't talk to me about that [ __ ]
they knew better i'm uploading i'm
downloading they would talk about
downloading and how what what what's it
like in your hotel room is your computer
coming in and they would sit around like
three jerk offs him duncan and brian and
joe and i don't know if something's
buffering you know whatever the [ __ ] it
is and i would sit there like i don't
know what these guys are talking about i
wouldn't even think of bringing a
computer with me on the road right
wouldn't even think it wasn't like a
computer on the road i didn't want a
[ __ ] computer in my house
so you never like not use porn to get to
masturbate jack off i guess no really
they would talk about
all this disgust and videos
and then at night we would get high and
go to somebody's room and they would
show me all this stuff that's how i
learned about little things yeah and
they showed me myspace and they showed
me
well i had a hotmail but i lost the code
years ago i still got the same one i
feel like you had it on a piece of paper
in your wallet it's like when someone
teaches their grandmother about i had
that hotmail account since 1990.
seven houston texas stacy pocaludo who i
spoke to